users where its marquee is lit up in the
band's
signature color purple it's not alone
more than a dozen others will follow
suit you wore your purple i did you look
smooth black butter you got it i lost a
bet they're pulling in las vegas like no
other the k-pop group bts performs the
first of four concerts at allegiant
stadium tomorrow night and their fans
including brian are ready christian
casadas joining us now live near
allegiant stadium where fans have been
getting their gear for that concert
christian
that's right guys i'm not wearing purple
but let me tell you give me a few
minutes and i will be sporting the
purple but let me tell you all these
fans are out here continue to come down
these are all bts fans are making their
way slowly to allegiant stadiums parking
lot making their way to get that hard to
get official exclusive gear for the band
some of these hot items i'm told are the
hoodies the key chains with the las
vegas logo and even the trading cards
with the images of the band members some
fans that i just spoke to telling me
some of those items are out of stock as
bts fever continues to sweep las vegas
you never really expect what is ever
going to happen especially with bts like
their music like what they produce
bts fever continues to sweep around the
globe and las vegas is no exception the
k-pop group taking over the town with
four sold-out concerts and their fan
base known as bts army can't get enough
i've been wanting this blanket literally
for like ever so finally got it because
it sells out super quickly and then i
also got this hoodie julie and her
friends are from out of town they rushed
to allegiant stadium for official
merchandise sales at two in the morning
along with thousands more the fans are
collectors we like to collect
various items t-shirts jackets
especially exclusive items melody lee is
a las vegas resident and part of the
local bts army but good luck finding her
this week she's hitting all the themed
pop-up spots on and off the strip over
the course of several days i went to the
photo exhibit already fantastic they it
was basically like a museum of all of
their photos from their concerts i also
went to the pop-up shop which was
amazing it was very interactive fans
spending hundreds and even thousands of
dollars on merchandise on top of the
concert hotel and travel expenses which
they say is all worth it honestly having
like the time of your life because
that's exactly what they want from you
is to have like the time of your life
and just to go out there and like make
the most of everything that you can do
all right back out here live we're
taking a look at one of the lucky bts
fans that just scored some merchandise
here now many of these fans are just
thrilled about this wave of bts events
here in las vegas because they tell me
this doesn't happen in other cities and
before we go brian and denise
i was checking in because i was going to
get you guys some official swag from
some of your favorite colors with the
band members but i'm told they only have
the extra extra extra large shirts so
i'll come back tomorrow and maybe get
you guys something christian gossip is
live local now